when some people say trunk versus
Sanders they say what Donald Trump is or
what Americans like so much about him
they should really more like about you
do you think you should be in Donald
Trump's position should i be in Donald
Trump positions um I think I do a better
job but I mean I have young kids and I
think honestly that entrepreneurs can
have more impact on this country in this
world and innovators can have more
impact on this country in this world
than the President of the United States
do you think the current administration
celebrates entrepreneurship we know
they've done a lot to celebrate tech ya
know I do I mean I've been you know I've
met with President Obama multiple times
and I've been at different functions
that they've had that definitely do
celebrate entrepreneurship now is he
done everything possible to you know
make things better for octopus no of
course not but you know from the local
level to the federal level there's way
too much as minister of iya that makes
it hard and over burdens entrepreneurs
but you know that's a different topic
for different but is are we sending a
mixed message when Mitt Romney said
corporations are people he got vilified
for it but it is corporate America that
creates jobs provides healthcare gives
them important that right okay so you
know we take one element a gen Xer type
approach or I baby boomer type approach
whatever it may be to look at
corporations and entrepreneurship kids
today Millennials and Gen Z look at
completely different today and I think
this is part of the attraction to Bernie
Sanders because you would think why are
kids so into somebody who is a
self-proclaimed socialist because when
you look at the most successful
companies that come on shark tank when
someone comes on shark tank and there
are 20 something inevitably and I've
invested in many of these companies they
have a social component to what they do
right so they've copied the toms shoes
models 1 for 1 i've got a company combat
flip flops that I just invested in and
they educate Afghani women they provide
schooling for Afghani women you know our
Riveter is another one of the companies
all these companies have these social
components you know I have a company on
the living christmas tree that delivers
Christmas trees and all they do is hired
veteran all right but here's the thing
these companies that cut these
entrepreneurs who come on shark tank I
watch you you push them on
ability one of the things we've seen in
Silicon Valley especially among
Millennials and their new world of the
way they want to live in the way they
want to work these companies don't make
money right so here's the difference so
is this the time when these tech
companies are going to start to fall off
okay two things right you're talking
about two different completely different
things so there's the day-to-day
companies that come on shark tank
definitely geared towards profits but if
you want to sell to Millennials you
better have a social component so when
Mitt Romney talked about companies are
people corporations are people i think
it was pre true social economics or
social entrepreneurship that we're
seeing now because today to sell to
millennials you better be helping
somebody because those are the brands
those are the companies that they want
to buy from right so that's part one
right so put that over here that's
outside of Silicon Valley for the most
part in Silicon Valley they're in their
own little world they are they have
insulated themselves they have lost
touch with reality you've got kids
because they graduated from this school
or that school with an idea they get an
eight million dollar valuation they
raise two million dollars keep
seventy-five percent of the company
right it's ridiculous and I've been
saying it for a long time so what's
going to happen there they're getting
written down to nothing a lot of them
are going out of business literally if
you invest in ninety-five percent of the
Silicon Valley's that are coming out
where have come out in last year the
minute you write that check and it
clears you should write it to zero
because that's what it's worth really
these companies have no chance no chance
well look there's companies that are
good right I'm saying ninety-five
percent of them are done before they
started out of the Silicon Valley five
percent are going to be amazing